um well i heard you go on very  adventurous trips with your husband  um i just heard about a crazy  adventurous one from ed um what's one of  y'alls  oh gosh we did um a late honeymoon  in africa which was one of the best trip  well the best trip probably of my life  um  yeah the best times some epic adventures  there all sorts of crazy encounters  what did you do with safari i've done  i've done this far as they're amazing  it was it was truly one of the most  amazing experiences  ever um yeah we found with sharks that  was pretty  amazing um yeah just you know it was it  was  uh magic really the whole trip we loved  it  um yeah now were these sharks uh  swimming around your cage were they uh  hungry or were they just big fans of  yours  but most likely hungry but they you know  they they throw  chum in there and and you know  it was it was crazy